自分で徳利した形で英語言葉を勉強するか
[音楽]
ん
ん分
今日はこちら stick up です
今日はそのどういう風にして自分で徳利した形で英語および
言葉を勉強するかという話なんですよ
もうこのビデオを好きであればぜひ登録してください
金のところでクリックすればーあの子
知らせ届けします捨て僕と一緒にリンギでまた
言葉も言葉を勉強してください
あの大部分の人たちは言葉を勉強するときに学校行くわけですよ
その学校行ってですね先生がその言葉を
教えて
くれると
醤油態度の人が多いはいいですよ
どういう内容のものを選んか効くかどういう文法の部分を勉強するか
すべて先生が来ません先生がこの言葉を知ってると生徒が
言葉は知らないと
だから当然知らない人が
知ってる人から勉強するわけですよだけども僕のそのやり方までそれとは違うんですよ
やはり言葉はある
英語なら英語日本語なる日本語この言葉が存在するわけですよ
誰でもそれをその発見っていうか
勉強することができるわけですよ
学校行っても行かなくても
自分で勉強したいといけない自分の頭がにその言葉を
入らないといけないと
いうことなんですよじゃあそのだから独自でその
そう誘導した形て勉強何必要ですよ
学校いっても同6とあの徳利した形で勉強しないといけない
それをどういうフレーズすればいいまぁ僕の場合は自分のリンクを誓ってるわけでしょ
だから
そこにたくさんのなよが合う
そしてできるだけ毎日ですねそういう
例えば構成あるでしょそのコースの好守全コースのオーディオ
もう
聞くように高機能があるわけですよ
それが押せばそしてもうその日はその構想
ピークんですよ
順番で聞いてもいいし合いが車夫してですねあのー
あれですよ
混ぜてキーこともあるわけですよで聞いたら知らない部分があるから
そ龍馬は良い読むんですよだから僕の独立した勉強方法がそういうふうに聞くという
ところから
始まるわけですよ
で独立した形で勉強するというのは自分でその言葉に良いも
卓数はですよ勅命ず聞く
4位れておくしかし当然
知らない単語があるからまぁそれをマーレン機であればオンラインの
自主調べるわけですよ単語やフレーズを調べられるわけですよ
文法については知らない部分があればあのん
ボコいつも僕の本を買うんですよ
たをけれども
薄い小ちゃなこれはたまたまオランダ語ですけれどもこれだけしか入らないんですよ
白砂のドリルとかてすとか質問とか実際はいらないと言う簡単な説明
基本のパターンの説明
その説明読んでねを忘れるかっ
もう一度何回も読まなければならない
だからこういうような本は何回も何か違ったところへ
同じロール同じ説明を見て少しずつ
頭に入ってくるんですよ
生えてくるというのは
たぁくさん聞いたたくさん経験があるからその5すでにしまぁ知ってる経験してある
ものに対する説明がその説明が確認っていう形で入ってくるんですよ
知らないものに関してはですね説明を見ても無意味です
無意味だから
独立した形で勉強するというのはまず最初の間はあ
あるいは後でもですね比較的簡単が繰り返しの多い
立場リンクの場合はミニストーリーよ何回も何回も聞いてそういうその訓練の巻き方
読み方と後は面白いないよ
アパートがしてよああ
本屋
自分の評議のある分野のその
そういうコンテンツを聞いたり読んだりなの両方やるわけですよ
自分のそれが自分の戦略もちろんみんな
皆さんですね自分に合うような戦略
選択しないといけないけれどもやはり十分なコンテンツ
自分に合うようなコンテンツを探せないところ
僕は中国語を勉強した時に
これ50年前ですけれども香港の本屋さん行って
そういうアレですよテキストそして合意を英語に翻訳した合意用の
持ったもの
のそういうもんしかし中国の政治や歴史やそういう
のあるいはた
現代小説
ダウンバーン
で下りのちっちゃなねっ
短編小説ていいですかそういうような剤を探したわけだが
独立した形で勉強するというのは自分でコンテンツを探さないと言いません
先生がこれ
読みなさいとそうじゃなしにこれが自分にとって面白いというものをよ今
さらにその感情が良くなる
スキーな声を聞いたりそれを自分で選ばれる先生が選ぶんじゃなくて自分でな
そして言葉について何か知りたい時に
先生が唯一のその
源じゃないんですよその言葉のいわゆる説明ですね
英語なら英語
google すればすぐ知りたい部分だけ
隅部すれば説明学そしてその時に自分がそれを敷いたいといういい
その
あるいは積極的にですね講義心があれば
多分
紹介できるんですよしかし先生が今日はこれ教えるから
特価室やらせますからいうような形で勉強しにくいと思います
いずれ自分で
学行かなくてもいいし行ってもいいし
ほとんどそれ指導権を取って勉強しないといけません
すぎな内容を聞いたり読んだり
必要なときに
を調べてみ
そういうふうにすれば楽しくそれはすべて
あの
やりやすくなってくるんですよそしてはい
ことはいっていうのはもう態度積極的に好きです
成功するだろうそういう積極的な対応とやはり時間だからそういう風にド級独立した形
で勉強すると胎動も積極的で十分な時間を
使うことになるわけですよだから病院は今日はそこまで
ああああん
自分で勉強する方法独立した形の
その言葉の勉強について話ししたかったんですまあ今日はそこまでじゃどうも
ありがとう
ban
うん
me